an employee of ey formerly known as
Ernst and Young has been found dead in
the office in Australia after a work
event this is what I want to talk about
today so welcome to a new coffee break
here on my channel firm learning the
place where I want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career the death of this ey employee is
what everyone has been talking about in
the Consulting community in the last one
or two weeks and in this video I want to
First discuss the circumstances that are
known in this specific case but then
second in a more General way talk about
the work life balance the working hours
that you can currently expect to find in
Consulting I will third talk about
travel how much travel will be expected
from you in Consulting in this day and
age and then fourth I will make some
conclusions what in my humble opinion
this means for the attractiveness of a
Consulting career and also how this
change compared to the pre-corona time
let's start with the first topic the
death of the consultant in Australia and
also to make this clear by no means want
to imply that the working conditions at
the Y were actually responsible for the
death this is not what I want to say
with this video so if you do read the
associated news reports there do seem to
be some signs that the lady involved was
indeed overworked in the last weeks it
was busy season and if you read rather
than other places there were other
Consultants saying that especially in
audit the sector where this lady worked
from July to September so the busy
season where many of the big corporates
need to complete and finalize their
books the working hours can be crushing
some people talked about 70 80 hours
plus the were expected from you other
big four employees from that region
reported that working in these firms
felt like running an Iron Man being part
of an Iron Man contest where allegedly
some seniors would tell you that you
should quote unquote either survive or
leave and it was this mindset that
people were saying that when well if I
needed to work like this if I did it in
the past then it surely must be fair for
you as the junior to now go through the
same thing live through the same hours
as well and in the specific case any why
there also seem to be some other
circumstances adding on it apparently
this lady was from India and on a work
visa in Australia this can put
additional pressure on people because
your Visa is usually directly attached
to your employment and if you do not
manage to find another employer who
sponsors your Visa if you quit your job
you do not meet your Visa conditions
anymore which might even lead to your
deportation so to some extent these
people seem to be locked in into the
situation and allegedly some of the
firms are also taking advantage of that
we're not promoting these people and
leaving them on Junior positions because
they know that they cannot really leave
now as many things are still unknown
about this specific case I want to
rather abstract the topic to a more
General discussion about working hours
and work life balance in Consulting and
I will take this from two different
sites first I will talk about my own
humble experiences having worked at an
mbb strategy consulting firm in Germany
and then I also did surveys on LinkedIn
on Instagram collecting many of your
inputs also considering the current
situation which is surely different
today after covet all of this with the
go to hopefully help you make more
informed decisions whether you want to
join consulting or not so that everyone
knows what he or she is getting into let
me start by talking about what I know
the reality has been if you would have
worked in a company like BCG Bain or
McKinsey up until the pandemic so
typical work week looked like that that
on Monday morning you would fly into the
client of needing to wake up at 4 or 5
AM because of course you need to take
one of the earlier flights then you
would work there you would fly back to
your office location on Thursday evening
and in this time period usually Monday
Tuesday Wednesday it was I'd say the
average to work until midnight or so
often of course with breaks at lunch and
for dinner and so on so in these days if
you were able to close your laptop at 10
pm that would have been a great day
Thursday was the day where you were
flying home there often you arrived home
between 8 and 10 pm or so and here
indeed then afterwards usually there
wasn't much work to be done anymore so
Thursday was already a bit more relaxed
in terms of working hours and then
Friday usually was a quite regular day
often until 5 PM or 6 p.m and then
people were calling it a day and this is
all something quite important there was
a big culture of protecting the weekends
of avoiding weekend work surely if there
was a very important business need
sometimes you were asked to do some work
on the weekend as well but this was
definitely just the exception if by the
way you're interested to learn more
about how such a typical work week in
the life of a consultant at McKenzie BC
G band looks like I will insert a video
here above where I've discussed this in
detail in the past so now the question
is how did this change after the
pandemic now we'll talk more about home
office and travel in a moment but just
in terms of working hours also when I
asked you the consensus seem to be that
overall nothing really changed so the
hours are more or less comparable same
thing usually Monday to Wednesday until
midnight or so is normal 10 pm would be
a bit early after midnight would be late
and Friday being a bit of a slower day
and weekends still being free now there
are some nuances to this some people say
well actually got a little bit worse
because for instance the Thursday where
people used to travel and where this
used to be a bit of a slower day as well
now it's just a regular work day for all
the people who just work from the home
office so actually this added to the
hours but then on the other hand some
people say well on the other hand side
the Mondays there you don't need to wake
up stand up that early because you don't
need to catch a flight the leaves at 6
a.m or 7 am so you can sleep in a bit
longer on Mondays so this seems to be
more or less balancing out of course I'd
be interested to hear your opinions as
well leave a comment if you've had very
different experiences than that so what
is my reflection on these working hours
and of course everyone is different the
fact that ours like this will have on
people might differ quite significantly
so let me just share my personal humble
experience and I must say I think the
most important thing that you just need
to have in your mind is a mindset when
Journey Consulting is that during the
week you focus of 100
on your work so you just should not have
the expectation that in the evenings you
have time to do other things meet with
friends relax with a Netflix movie
Follow pursue a hobby this will just not
be part of the reality and you need to
be okay with that and for me a joint
Consulting fresh out of University I
never really experienced differently
after starting working so for me it was
just natural it did feel like I adapted
to this situation quite well and then of
course the good thing which I think also
distinguishes Consulting from other
professions such as Investment Banking
was that the weekends were free so from
Friday afternoon Friday evening you had
some free time to really recharge the
batteries and keep up with your social
life that being said the hours can be
brutal though they differ also
significantly by project so sometimes
you have a tougher project sometimes an
easier project but especially on the
tougher projects I remember several
weeks sometimes even months where just
worked so much that I just failed so
exhausted and for sure this would not
have been healthy for me to continue
working in such an environment now for
years and years and years surely
everyone is different but for me it was
clear that at some point I did want to
make the transition make the switch to a
more also family friendly environment
let's talk about more travel and working
from home before and after the pandemic
and as I just shared before the pandemic
the schedule looked like Monday to
Thursday you would be usually co-located
with the client at the client occasion
unless the project location was your
hometown this did mean significant
travel every single week and then on
Friday at least the way I experienced it
it was absolutely okay to just work from
the home office The Only Exception being
that if your Project Lead was from your
office as well he or she might have
asked you to join him or her in the
office and then of course home office
was not possible on Fridays anymore so
what does the situation look like today
and what you have shared with me via the
surveys is that actually there's a very
significant variance even within the
firm and this depends on first your
client needs and preferences what
actually the client wants you to do
second the preferences of your team lead
and also of your partners and third to
some extent you might even be able to
also as a junior to influence these
types of decisions and currently there
are three Arch types of client service
models that are emerging the first Arch
type is the old model where Consulting
teams are still flying in will spend
Monday to Thursday with the client on
their project this does not seem to be
the norm anymore but it's still used if
the client requests this if the client
wants this or for whatever other reason
the partner has discussed with the
client that this is the setup that makes
sense for the specific project the
second archetype seems to be one that
seems to be especially relevant for the
mbb firms McKinsey BCG Bain and this is
that you're not necessarily co-located
with your client anymore often also the
client organizations work remote also
from the client side or the employees
won't be in the office anymore but
instead just the team internally decides
to co-locate in any of the offices and
what this means is that then often
officers being chosen at the beginning
of the project and then all team members
who are not originally from that office
need to come to the this office every
week so this means that the team members
that are based in other offices need to
fly in Monday morning will spend the
whole work week with the team in the
office and then Thursday evening they
can fly out to their home office again
and then spend the Friday in the home
office indeed now of course the office
location will often be chosen based on
the locations of the team members so
many team members already based in one
office then likely this is going to be
the office where everyone will be
working from so for a part of the team
this might be quite convenient but of
course this means that all the other
people still need to fly in have all the
travel that is going on at least for
this part of the team the travel
situation did not change much before the
pandemic but of course project by
project this will likely be mixed up so
on average you should be better off if
your goal your preference is to not
travel that much now to the third Arch
type and this is the fully remote or at
least hybrid model where people can
decide to spend the whole week from the
home office or at least a certain number
of days from the home office instead of
being co-located in your own office this
seems to be more common for Big Four
firms what you shared with me but some
project teams also the mbb firms follow
a similar model but what is the
implication of this does a higher number
of home office days actually improve
work-life balance and here actually I
got quite mixed feedback so on the one
hand side I heard that yes this does
lead to a better lifestyle you have a
bit more flexibility throughout the day
surely if you're family you might have
the opportunity to have lunch with your
kids maybe with your significant other
but there's also quite big group who
told me that actually they perceived the
work-life balance to have worsened due
to this for the reason that now all this
time that you usually spend in travel
also Thursday evenings where you were
just at the airport in the airplane this
was usually time where you were able to
wind down to just relax a bit maybe
think about some other things not think
about work all day and then again once
you arrived home you had more time for
your ourselves nowadays if you work from
home you can expect to be dialed into
video calls from very early morning
until very late at night with very
little breaks in between and this in
itself is a new level of just mental
stress pressure on your mental health it
wasn't there before while you're just
sitting in the team room having eye to
eye conversations spending time maybe at
the coffee machine with the client these
are types of interruptions and breaks
which are far less common today in
addition to that before the pandemic
video calls weren't really a thing yes
you often had conference cards but these
were usually telephone conferences so
voice only and this then adds to just an
additional level of stress they need to
be sitting in front of the camera
managing your looks and appearance you
cannot just stand up and do something
else while being dialed into a telephone
conference and all of this just adds an
additional layer of stress to the
reality of work and I can personally
talk only relate but I absolutely
understand the advantages of video
conferences it is surely much more
comfortable and convenient to just talk
via voice without an image of yourself
visible at every single point in time so
let's now move to the last section and
this is my reflection what all of this
will mean for the attractiveness of a
Consulting career and I'd say there are
some positives and some negatives let's
start with the positives first of all
the work from home model adds
flexibility to your schedule you will
have more time with your family
potentially with your kids I do think
that this is a positive step towards
making the Consulting career more family
friendly in addition you will have some
flexibility in the Staffing process to
actively choose for projects for studies
that meet your preferences also when it
comes to being co-located to the working
model all of this gives you agency and
helps you select the projects the best
meet your needs but there are some
negatives as well and for the reasons
discussed earlier I'm a bit worried that
that working from home in Consulting
will lead to even more mental health
issues to even more pressure on the
people sitting in front of the screen
from early morning until late at night
being dialed into one video conference
after video conference is surely not the
healthiest way to spend your day second
I'm afraid that the increasing trend of
working from home takes away one of the
most significant learning opportunities
that are associated to working and
Consulting and these are regular client
interactions so in the old model you
spend Monday to Thursday almost the full
week together with your clients you will
sit together with them every single day
have informal conversations with them
build relationships with them in my
humble opinion this was one of the most
significant learning aspects of the
career in Consulting and sure if you
work from home you will still have video
calls with these people but it's just
not the same thing and I know some
people might disagree but also looking
at my current role as an executive in a
startup company if you talk to clients
just via video calls and compare this to
clients you have met face to face in
workshops and so on the difference of
the relationship is so significant I'm
afraid that a lot of these types of
experiences and learning opportunities
are now missing while in this video we
talked a lot about the negative sides of
working and Consulting I do want to
stress that I look back at my time in
Consulting in a very very favorable way
my time in Consulting was absolutely
instrumental to both my personal and my
professional development yes the hours
can be tough but it will also grow
significantly with the experience now if
you are currently working in Consulting
as well let me know in the comments
whether all of this matches your current
experiences and of course if you took
any video out of this video at all hit
the like button for the YouTube
algorithm And subscribe big big thanks
to all the members of the channel as
well my name is Heinrich I release
videos every single week all the best to
you and bye bye